My husband recently had his lap tonsil with a tumor removed on Hunch because of lymphoma.
He has been 13 days down and just getting off the pain meds and able to return to normal
foods.
They remain swelling in the neck and lymph nodes.
When may he return to the hyperbaric oxygen treatment, high dose vitamin C drips and
far infrared sauna treatments.
Thank you kindly.
I would say you can start those now.
For sure.
I don't think you have any issue with hyperbaric oxygen, I don't think you have any issue with
the vitamin C drips.
The only thing that you might have issue with is the infrared sauna because it is increasing
your temperature and can increase some inflammation temporarily.
So just watch that.
If you feel like you're getting a little swelling, I would go slow on the sauna.
That's all I would say.
But otherwise everything else you could go ahead and take.
And praying for him, I know he was going to go ahead with that surgery so I'm so glad
that he's doing well.